Hi Anne, thank you very much.
Well, you know, it's actually been lighter than usual.
People really took notice of the morning to stay away from Doyle Drive.
We're going to show you some live look here in that area.
Here's a live look at the Golden Gate Bridge...
...where you can see traffic isn't doing too badly.
We did see some slight delays in the right hand side there...
...just as you approach the toll plaza but that's actually eased up quite a bit...
...so again, it has been very light.
Elsewhere, some of our alternates though have been quite busy.
We were seeing delays across the Bay Bridge.
At one point, they did turn the metering lights on...
...so it has been busier than usual for the Bay Bridge.
In fact, you can see the upper deck of the Bay Bridge crawling along into San Francisco,...
...not too bad though out of San Francisco into Oakland.
Things have been lighter than usual.
They do have traffic control on scene.
Again, we have seen some slight delays in the turn lanes.
Now, the turn lanes are available for commuters.
Typically, they're only available for buses as you travel through there on to California and Geary...
...but again, we are seeing some busy conditions...
...on that southbound side of Park Presidio.
So hopefully, things will wrap up by 5 AM as scheduled.